Birds are known for their numerous ways
of communicating,
through sound, body language,
or in one case, a strange combination of both.
Crested pigeons are indigenous to Australia.
Aside from their wicked mohawks,
there doesn’t seem to be anything
too special about them.
That is, until they take to the air.
When the crested pigeon flaps its wings, they whistle.
With each wing beat,
the upstroke produces a 1.3 kilohertz low note
and the downstroke produces a 2.9 kilohertz high note.
While this whistle has been known for some time,
scientists were curious.
Was this just a quirk of biology,
or a method of communicating?
The distinctive sound was discovered to be
coming from the eighth feather on the pigeon's wing.
When this feather was removed from the bird,
the high note disappeared along with it.
And when the feather was placed in a wind tunnel,
the high frequency sound was heard once again.
When the researchers played back audio recordings
of slow wing beats, the birds stayed where they were,
but when they played faster wing beats,
the birds were more likely to try and flee.
Because the notes cycle back and forth
between high and low, the speed of the cycle informs
the pigeons whether there is danger present,
or if it’s just another bird taking off.
This discovery means that even though
the crested pigeon isn’t much of a talker, there
there are more ways for birds to communicate audibly,
not with their mouths, but with their movements.